après trois mois d'après négociation en
train industrielle et grande
distribution la pression pour limiter la
hausse des prix vient de Bercy cet
après-midi Bruno Le Maire a à nouveau
reçu les acteurs de la grande
distribution pour tenter d'obtenir un
engagement sur des mesures qui protègent
le pouvoir d'achat des Français car si
le ministre de l'Économie réfute le
terme de mars rouge c'est bien un
printemps d'envoler des prix qui
s'annonce et alors regardez
la première vache qui l'a vu comme vous
pouvez le voir et ben c'est
Sarah
qui défait devant Sarah qui est un peu
désemparée malheureusement les
consommateurs ils ont face à eux un mur
d'inflation et les prix vont augmenter
en moyenne de 8 9 10% sur les semaines
qui viennent personne ne le conteste
tous les distributeurs sont d'accord
avec cette prévision là ça va piquer
pour les consommateurs faut-il pour
autant s'attendre à un mur d'inflation
dès les prochains jours non selon cette
expert
ça va être lisser dans le temps c'est
pour ça que vous aurez des augmentations
oui malheureusement au mois de mars mais
également au mois d'avril et
probablement également au mois de mai et
peut-être au mois de juin mesdames et
messieurs vous suivez en direct la plus
grande escroquerie de l'histoire de la
télévision alors face à ces nouvelles
hausses le gouvernement ne veut pas
laisser le champ libre il promet que des
mesures prendront tes faits d'ici le 15
mars
ils aiment vraiment être caressés ils
aiment le contact
il y a des lacs
ils aiment être grattés sur le dos comme
nous les êtres humains
le problème c'est qu'on est dans un pays
où on crée nous-mêmes la sinistreuse
c'est-à-dire que la ministre nous dit
attention mars rouge les médias du matin
au soir nous disent ah attention
l'alimentation ça explose en mars tout
le premier semestre et alors est-ce que
vous prenez vraiment les gens pour des
cons story s'en rendent pas compte
eux-mêmes il y a besoin de leur dire et
de le rabâcher du matin au soir donc on
est en train de créer une psychose et
une sinus rose nous-même des chercheurs
ont révélé que mettre ses doigts dans le
nez favoriserait la maladie d'Alzheimer
c'est vrai ou c'est faux non c'est faux
là je peux vous dire que ça va être un
des arguments qui va faire que ceux qui
la font genre les vierge et pleurer oh
non jamais je me mets les doigts dans le
nez vont quoi qu'il arrive arrêter de le
faire c'est vrai
quand je vois le prix des poivrons
presque 9 euros le kilo ça devient pas
possible eh ben on va faire le régime
cet été sur la plage on est tous maigres
il y a des sites où il y a des médiums
ou pas on peut avoir des consultations
est-ce que selon les moments où c'est
difficile dans la ville les gens ils ont
besoin d'un coup sûr les réseaux sur
Youtube
vous voyez je suis d'ailleurs
modératrice d'une chaîne d'une médium
célèbre et c'est vrai que ça prend une
ampleur
ah oui c'est la crise
parce que c'est pas simplement une icône
qui tombe si c'était que ça ça serait
terminé c'est qu'on lève une pierre et
on voit tout ce qu'il y a de nauséabond
dans la société française
la violence la drogue dans la société
française dans l'humanité dans l'homme
et ce que je peux terminer
bon je m'occuperai du reste je crois
[Musique]
tellement tellement rigolo de lécher la
table c'est cool
la violence la drogue le sexe la
prostitution la pédocriminalité tout
cela tout ce qui est nauséabonde dans
notre société c'est pas simplement
qu'une icône qui tombe
tu es un bonhomme de sucre
on va faire ressortir tout sucre
qui se produit
quoi
de synthèse vous connaissiez les gosses
aujourd'hui vous connaissiez tout ça
c'est ça que ça révèle l'affaire Palmade
c'est pas si ce n'était que une star qui
tombe on en parlerait dix fois moins
[Musique]
c'est le café de la forêt c'est le café
quand il conduisent l'anus
[Applaudissements]
devant donc une prestation dans un train
qui n'existe plus elle les envoie
visiteurs village ou les habitants ne
veulent pas voir les touristes c'est
magnifique Bernard sabat on va se
régaler on va se régaler le marché aux
bestiaux et quand arriver sur place on a
trouvé trois femmes assis sur un
trottoir avec trois poules
comme les étudiants qui se développent
pour les éclairer
et là je peux vous dire que regardez
comme il est tout doux il se laisse
faire c'est vraiment très agréable et
surtout surtout il est très très chaud
et ça je peux vous dire que c'est bien
pour un matin comme aujourd'hui
ça donne très envie en tout cas mais
surprise l'exercice est plus compliqué
que prévu
quoi que c'est dans le dans les
testicules moi je pensais que c'était ça
bravo bravo Valérie et c'est vraiment
magnifique poisson
pas tout de suite tout à l'heure en
revanche je veux bien faire une bise à
Valérie il y a pas de problème merci en
tout cas merci à vous merci